it's easy to think that Europe was so
successful in taking over the world
because they had like better ships or
guns or whatever but when you actually
look at the whole story you see that it
was actually just a perfect storm of
technology and timing and ideology and
religion of a few key inventions and
what I want to show you in this video is
that one of the biggest reasons that
Europe was able to take over the world
is because of the invention of the
modern Corporation a collection of
people who don't know each other but who
pull their money together for the same
goal extracting resources from far away
places so this is part two of how Europe
stole the world
foreign
hey before we dive into this story fully
I need to tell you about the sponsor of
today's video who made this video
possible which is policy genius policy
genius helps you get life insurance kind
of a topic that none of us want to talk
about but it's a topic we should talk
about because life insurance is very
important true story I was doing a
policy genius sponsorship last year and
in the middle of the sponsorship
realized wait I need life insurance and
I literally went to my own link and
signed up for life insurance for me and
my wife it's a true story getting life
insurance used to be kind of hard but
policy genius has modernized this
process by making it easy to browse lots
of different plans from lots of
different insurance companies they have
no incentive to recommend one more than
the other they literally just take your
information make it super easy for you
to see the plans available to you like
seriously this was a really easy process
I didn't have to go into some doctor's
office I didn't have to do anything I
literally filled out a bunch of stuff
talk to someone on the phone and before
you know it I'm seeing the different
plans and it being explained how they
work the thing that convinced me the
most I think was that life insurance is
way cheaper when you're young and so now
is kind of the time to do it to like
lock yourself into a good policy at a
good price with policy genius you can
find life insurance policies that start
at 17 a month and that's for like a half
a million dollars of coverage there's no
weird fees and they're not like gonna go
sell your information I mean there's a
reason why they literally have thousands
of five star reviews on trustpilot and
Google no one wants to talk about
needing to use life insurance but your
loved ones deserve a financial safety
net and you deserve a smarter way to
find and buy it to start comparing
quotes and simplify Insurance buying go
to policygenius.com Johnny Harris link
is also in the description thank you
policy genius for supporting this video
Let's dive back into how Europe stole
the world
okay quick catch up on where we are in
the story in part one we talked about
how Spain and Portugal went out to get
in on trade and accidentally ran into a
bunch of land they decided was unclaimed
and it turned into a big race to see who
could take over as much land as possible
after about a century of this other
Europeans start to take notice of this
model of expansion
and they realized that it's a great way
to enrich your country some of these
countries have been dabbling in
imperialism but in the early 1600s it
was time to get serious the first to
follow suit were the Dutch who were
becoming really good at navigating water
and making maps and doing business they
decided to follow Portugal's lead and go
around the bottom of Africa stopping
right here at the very tip in what today
is known as Cape Town South Africa they
established a permanent colony of white
settlers whose descendants would go on
to become a major part of South Africa's
history
[Music]
the Dutch used their Prime position in
Cape Town to restock on their way to
Southeast Asia where they were trading
for spices with local Empires and
claiming serious amounts of land in what
is today Indonesia around the same time
at the start of the 1600s we see the
next kingdoms trying their hand at
large-scale imperialism meet the two
rookies on the Block
[Music]
England and France who would go on to
actually cause a lot of trouble on the
world map but for now they're just
getting started they for the most part
followed Spain's lead going west for the
Americas though England sent ships East
at this time as well anyway here in the
Americas they showed up and light
colonizers before them found lots of
land and lots of people living on that
land kind of inconvenient these aren't
real people right they don't actually
own this land you can hear the English
people like sort of saying to themselves
so they came up with a new very useful
tool it was a mental tool in addition to
guns and smallpox and alliances with
local tribes that help them divide and
conquer the locals Europeans also
developed a complex set of legal
philosophies to convince themselves that
these people were not in fact capable to
claim any land after all they were
foragers they didn't Farm they couldn't
own this land because they didn't use it
for productive means they were sub-human
or at least non-civilized so they do not
deserve to own property very clever very
effective
and so now you see the next layer of
ideological thinking that was required
for these Europeans to justify their
land theft it was the need to dehumanize
the people living on these lands
[Music]
there's a letter from a British settler
who describes North America as a
Wilderness quote where none inhabit but
hellish fiends and brutish men this
dehumanizing paired really well with
another ideology that was very popular
at the time Christianity
a religion that told its followers to go
out and preach to everyone so that they
can be saved
perfect
we have these unrefined brutish fiendish
men and we have Christians who have the
power to save them anything is possible
now so by the late 1600s the colonizing
project is fully underway a lot of
Europeans are getting in on this but
here are the major players you've got
Spain and Portugal the ogs and then
you've got the Netherlands France and
England we need to make one thing clear
that the major reason why these European
Empires were so successful so quickly
was because they were really the first
to start trading by sea in the Western
Hemisphere so while Jesus and saving and
whatever was a big part of the
justification of Europeans going out and
feeling entitled to take land he became
less and less of a part of the picture
especially for the Dutch who basically
were just like who cares about Jesus we
want profit
and this is the next phase of the story
of how Europe took over the world we'll
call this chapter private Empire and
frankly it's one of the most important
things to know about this history
remember that European imperialism
started as a desire for trade to trade
with big empires in the east then
surprise we found all this land we'll
call it unclaimed and we'll start
claiming it while dehumanizing the
natives in the process remember okay a
lot of that was funded by governments
like kings and stuff but eventually the
citizens themselves of these places
realized that they could make a business
out of this and again this is where the
Dutch wrote The Blueprint
so now instead of asking the ruler for
support they could just get together a
bunch of people and form a corporation
like the First Corporation ever the
Dutch East India Company which would
fund private voyages and you a random
Dutch person in the 1600s could buy this
share a little portion of that company
to get in on a little bit of the profits
but if the profits are big enough then
everyone wins welcome to the era of
Corporations
now you have the Dutch with their new
Kickstarter campaign crowdfunding their
private Empire totally exceeding their
goal and these Dutch corporate Sailors
set out on the tried and true routes
that they already knew arriving to
Indonesia where they showed up not to
convert people to Jesus necessarily but
to harvest clothes and peppers as
efficiently as possible and to come home
and to sell them for a profit and fat in
the pockets of the shareholders who
funded the whole journey this isn't like
a surprising novel model to us today
because this is how the world runs but
at this point this was a new invention
oh and the government secretly loved
this they could give the company some
military power kind of ignore the
details of exactly how it was all going
down and still ensure that their country
got in on the world's richest and these
corporations leveled up really quickly
and became basically little private
Empires with the ability to take over
land build bases and establish
relationships with locals not for The
Prestige of like a king but so that they
could make more money for their
shareholders it was the private
investors who helped and get really big
really fast all through this invention
of the publicly traded company
and again it all started with the Dutch
East India Company and just like any
startup they were more Nimble than the
clunky Old Government they had good
funding they were private they were fast
they had an ability to undercut
competition all of this allowed them to
dominate this region when it came to
taking over land harvesting stuff and
bringing it back to Europe and because
they were the best operators they
eventually became the kingpins of all
spice trade in Europe things like black
pepper nutmeg cloves all of this because
of the countless trips that they were
taking between the East Indies and
Amsterdam
foreign
okay but it wasn't just the Dutch the
British also got in on this private
Empire idea
[Music]
see here this map it's the map of all of
the British private companies and
there's spheres of influence the
government doesn't own these places this
is like governments deported but by and
large private companies profit seeking
businessmen looking for stuff that they
couldn't get in their own country going
out and finding places where they could
over here in North America you have the
Virginia Company who's like going
hardcore on Tobacco and then it's sister
company the Plymouth Company one was
funded by a bunch of londoners and the
other the Plymouth Company funded by a
bunch of Rich dudes in Plymouth England
their job was to colonize land and to
build a business in the new world and
then if you look over here in the East
you see the British East India Company
who got really good at taking over giant
amounts of land in India
[Music]
the French were doing the same thing
they had their own West India company
that was colonizing the Caribbean to
grow and sell sugar and many many more
private Empire was such a powerful
accelerant to imperialism because it got
all of these private Empires to compete
with each other and to get better and
more efficient and to practice their
Conquest repetition fueled by
profit-seeking people they developed
amazing skills and they drew maths a lot
of beautiful beautiful Maps
[Music]
as a map nerd this is where I start to
like perk up I notice around this time
like sort of late 1600s and then the
1700s European Maps start to fill out
with more detail with more accuracy
because after all the more you can
depict on paper the better blueprint you
have to conquer land and exploit it so
by the 1700s Europe is now a different
world than what you saw in the 1400s you
start to see Kings living in insane
excess tea and coffee and chocolate and
tobacco and sugar they have access to so
much stuff and perhaps most
significantly it wasn't just for the
ultra Rich it was a new middle class the
Mercantile class of merchants who were
getting rich off of all this new
Commerce there was suddenly abundance
and with abundance comes time time to
sit around and think about Art and
Science all while sipping on coffee
harvested from far away lands
stimulating these European brains to
invent new ways of measuring things to
observe the world the Stars to
manipulate nature to make life better
and the competition between these
private Empires just grew and like with
any profit-seeking competition these
companies needed to keep leveling up how
much wealth they could attract from
these places how much land they could
take over to meet demand back home until
eventually they turned full on to the
most horrific version of profit-seeking
imperialism
foreign
stealing millions of people from most
notably here in West Africa taking them
to their new colonies and forcing them
to work
stealing and trading humans and forcing
them to work was not anything new to
this continent Islamic and African slave
Traders have been doing this for a very
long time but it was here in the 1700s
in this context of private Empire that
things really start to pick up as these
European Empires mostly England Portugal
and France took it to a new level to
fuel their highly optimized
shareholder-fueled private Empires so
optimized that the slave trade itself
was outsourced to a private company at
least in the case of England it was
Imperial profit-seeking efficiency at
its finest and most horrifying you can
almost hear the Glee and greed in the
voice of one English slave trader who
wrote quote what a glorious and
advantageous trade this is it is the
hinge on which all the trade of this
globe moves
foreign
but Europeans are starting to become
really enlightened at this point right
like they're starting to think through
like human rights and like equality and
starting to lay the groundwork for like
democracy yes but remember that these
Europeans had ideas in their minds that
were planted hundreds of years earlier
ideas that allowed them to invent things
like the new world and unclaimed land
that actually belonged to them they
applied a lot of those same ideas to the
slave trade a lack of Jesus a lack of
white European culture and Technology
making these people inferior in need of
Saviors to make use of their land their
resources and their bodies
foreign
about what's happening here yes this is
about profit yes this is about ideology
but this part is so damn important to me
because this is the foundation upon
which our modern world is built in this
moment these Empires were actually
building structures in our minds
structures that Define who has power who
is worth something who gets resources
who is permitted to lead to exploit to
benefit these structures were defined by
force by profit by greed and they
totally worked they put Europeans on top
giving them the prosperity and resources
to fuel scientific cultural and
political revolutions that allowed them
to keep holding on to that power to keep
exerting domination over others okay
yeah I get it half of you just had like
a conniption because of this like woke
sermon that you just got for me that's
not what this is okay I'm trying to look
at the history and tie it to today how
all of us live in a world that was built
off of what happened during this time
the ideas the movement of people that
happened because of this private Empire
that's not the woke mob that's just like
what happened sorry
even after the British people here on
the east coast of North America wanted
to break away from England and start
their own country where quote all men
are created equal they still couldn't
throw off the thirst for prophets that
slavery brought them these structures
were way too firm so they kept doing it
the momentum of private Empire was too
great to slow down at least not without
a bloody war that almost ripped this
Young Nation apart
[Music]
so that's private Empire a huge part of
Europe's ability to take over land on
the map and reshape the world in part
three of this series which is going to
be the final part I'm going to tell you
what happens next when these Powers
reach every part of the globe
establishing an order that they control
how we talk how we do our politics how
we trade including some really good
positive things that have made the world
better it's an order that was shaped by
these forces of European imperialism and
it's an order that still shapes all of
us today
[Music]